new tonight the family of the manager at
a local dottie's casino sharing more
about alicia gibolina the 60 year old
died after confronting a robbery suspect
outside of the bar near jones and
flamingo victoria saha is live at that
dotties after talking with gibolina's
daughter
[Music]
brian a memorial is left here for
gibolina symbolizing how much she was
adored by those who knew her gibolina
was working as a manager at this studies
when she was run over by a man who she
tried to confront after he stole a
customer's purse
[Music]
alicia gibolina described as an animal
lover and a selfless person she was just
all around just caring she would give
you the shirt off her back her daughter
diana gabalina still too distraught to
be on camera reflects back on the night
of may 11. i was trying to text and call
my mom and i thought she was just busy
at work
and on my way home i have to pass by the
store
and that's how i found out police say
28-year-old samuel schmidt went inside
dotties and stole a woman's purse
gabolina went outside to confront him in
the parking lot that is when police say
schmidt driving a stolen car ran her
over and drove away gabelina died at the
hospital this is just a senseless act
that i can't even
i'm still not even i can't wrap my brain
around it schmidt was arrested five days
later when police found him in
california it was very painful
i didn't i probably didn't sleep for
like a good three or four days although
nothing can bring her mom back diana has
a message for schmidt i don't think he
realizes what he took from my family
he
took the most important woman in my life
he'll have his day in court and he's
going to have to answer for what he did
schmidt is expected to be brought back
to nevada to face murder and robbery
charges he has had many run-ins with the
law and most was recently released from
prison in december police are still
looking for that car that schmidt used
that night reporting near flamingo and
jones victoria victoria's live local now